The benefits of bootstrapping are, I
mean there's so many, I could go on for
hours but I won't.
Benefits of bootstrapping essentially
come down to manifest destiny.
You are in control of
everything that you are doing.
Assuming that you're a sole proprietor
if you have partners, well you have some
control might be limited with with
a little bickering between your team.
But fundamentally you are in
control of your life, or
you will feel in control of
your life in what you're doing.
It's a very powerful sense
of being when you have that.
Second thing is you get to define
your own rules for the most part.
I mean, obviously, you can't stray off
the path and start breaking the laws.
But you are free to dictate
the path forward for yourself and
what that value means for
your company or your business.
The other advantages are you're not
going to ever become beholden to
somebody for the actions you're taking.
Now if the value that you are trading is
parts of your company or parts of your
product that go into perpetuity like
giving someone a percentage in exchange
for money, that's not bootstrapping.
That's selling your business or
selling your products, and
you want to steer away from
that if you're bootstrapping.
Bootstrapping is the pure creation
process of taking something or
creating something that
wasn't there before and
making it a thing that generates
value for you into the future.